with us now is Candida moss the Edward
Cadbury professor of theology at
Britain's University of Birmingham good
morning welcome so we we know about the
architecture and the history but tell us
about the theological significance of
Notre Dom well Notre Dame is really the
beating heart of Catholicism in France
this is where Joan of Arc was made a
saint this is where kings and emperors
are crowned where they hold funeral
masses for their presidents it's really
much more than a building it's more than
just a church it's inter woven with the
fabric of French history
well now the donations are pouring in
and you were saying that before they
were trying to raise money for the
restoration and it was not going well
those about that that's right
despite the fact that the French
government actually owns the Cathedral
building they had pledged only 25
percent of the 180 million dollar
renovations now the French government
has said that they will rebuild the
cathedral and donations are rolling in
including a hundred million euros from
the peano family are you confident that
it will be rebuilt and rebuilt the way
it was
that's a good question will they rebuild
it the way it was if they had laser
scanned the building that would be
possible and sort of relatively easy to
do but there are questions about whether
they will try to rebuild it in the same
way
given that the spire was actually
constructed in the nineteenth century
did you go this will mean for Catholics
in France because Catholicism in France
has had a bit on the wane yes I mean so
what do you think this will do the
actual you know belief system of people
in Paris
well it's obviously devastating and you
can see already a kind of spontaneous
renewal of piety you see people singing
in the streets you see them praying it's
probably going to bring people back to
church I expect that this Easter
churches in Paris will be jam-packed as
people mourn not only the crucifixion of
Jesus but also the loss of so much of
this Cathedral and then Candida I think
about this happening and holy week of
all weeks exactly right this is a period
of time when people flocked to churches
the crown of thorns that they rescued
from the cathedral is displayed and not
a dam on Good Friday and now where will
they display it even though they've
saved it so it's devastating to her
something like this happen in the most
holy of weeks what are their what other
artifacts were in the building and do
you know what they saved and what they
didn't say so in addition to saving the
crown-of-thorns they also saved part of
the tunic of Saint Louie a very
important Saint in the region they also
apparently saved items from the Treasury
so important religious statues what they
didn't save were the relics that were in
the spire of the cathedral itself they
had small portions of the relics of
Saint Denis and Saint Genevieve
in the spire that are presumed lost the
organ which is tremendously valuable in
damage but apparently intact and though
there's damage to the medieval stained
glass windows it's possible that they
might be saved too but when you look at
the building Candida as bad as it is it
could have been so much worse
Bravo to the firefighters there that's
absolutely right I think what was
shocking about this was the idea that
with all of our technological advances
we couldn't get it immediately under
control people were asking why what the
sprinkler system and that's good as a
medieval construction but yes the
firefighters did an amazing job right
now
professor Maas thank you so much for
being here thank you thank you
you